as entrepreneurs a lot of us start  because we want freedom but then as soon  as we quit our job and then start we  have absolute control and you cannot  have both freedom and control we love  the control but we want the freedom i  think entrepreneurship as a journey from  like a spiritual standpoint is a  consistent relinquishing of control at  each level you give up the fulfillment  and then you give up the selling and  then you give up the marketing and then  you give up the managing and then you  give up the leadership and then at some  point you give up even doing the vision  because there's somebody else who's just  as visionary or even more than you and  so at each of these things you're giving  up control but what you get back is  freedom